repérable de loin grâce à ses deux
cheminées de 220 mètres de haut elle
tourne depuis 1968 la centrale thermique
de Porcheville alimente en électricité
Paris et sa région en cas de pic de
consommation une activité essentielle
mais les centrales thermiques rejettent
des oxydes de soufre d'azote et
d'importantes quantités de CO2 principal
gaz à effet de serre fioul charbon gaz
c'est centrales fonctionnent à l'aide
d'énergie fossile dès 2008 EDF a modifié
la qualité du combustible utilisé nous
utilisons un fioul
ttbs donc très très basse teneur en
soufre avec moins 1% de soufre dans le
fioul donc de façon à respecter les
normes environnementales qui sont des
clés dans notre arrêté préfectoral de
plus une directive européenne devrait
s'appliquer dès janvier 2016 elle impose
de nouvelles normes concernant les
centrales thermiques
EDF à devancer cette directive la
combustion d'une unité de production a
été modifiée en 2011 25 millions d'euros
ont été investis pour divisés par 3 les
émissions de dioxyde d'azote en France
l'énergie thermique ne représente que 8
% pour 80 % d'énergie nucléaire
l'association Yvelines environnement
pointe surtout du doigt les autres
grands pays si l'on regarde la
production
de centrales thermiques en particulier à
charbon de la Chine de l'Inde des
États-Unis et même d'une partie de
l'Europe alors là effectivement on est
loin malheureusement des objectifs de
Kyoto un protocole qui prévoyait la
réduction de 5% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre entre 2008 et 2012
aujourd'hui les experts prévoient plutôt
une augmentation de ces rejets pour les
10 années à venir